The artist returns to the
copper centrepiece and
begins to weave,
starting with rattan
reeds that have also
soaked to make them more
pliable. She pulls the
reeds through the tabs
and inner crosses them
so that they fan out in
two directions.
She then braids cotton
string against the
centerpiece. This
creates a neat and sturdy
border all the way
around. She then trims
the ends of the strings.
Next, the artist weaves
rattan reeds parallel to
the cotton braid and
twining them with the
reeds that extend
outward. She creates one
row of these rigid
fibers for structure.
She's now ready for the
palm strands after the
soaking. The strands
remain soft and pliable
for many hours, so she
doesn't have to rush the
work.